the port of okedo is just five
kilometers
from the fukushima daiichi nuclear plant
it would be easy from here to mistake
the boat's masts
for the water cooling towers and cranes
on the reactor's roofs
it was only a year ago nine years after
the disaster
the port was allowed to be used again as
the level of radiation
had gone down to what are termed normal
limits
it was something the fishermen were
waiting for but today
they are not in the mood for fishing
they want to mourn all those lost in the
tsunami
kazuhiro watanabe would like his
photographs of traditional celebrations
in the town of soma
the birthplace of samurai warriors
to provide inspiration
i don't know maybe no one will come to
see my photos but if somebody does i
hope they inspire
them with courage to overcome the
challenges ahead
[Music]
japan has undergone a massive
reconstruction project
since 2011 rebuilding homes and ports
repairing ships and building hundreds of
kilometers of walls
along its coastline in case of another
tsunami
[Applause]
but when you travel along route 6 which
is just
3 kilometers from the fukushima plant
you realize there are signs showing the
amount of radiation
in the air
the fukushima plant has 6 reactors three
of them
to be removed that could take at least
10 years
then there's another 30 years for the
cleanup of the entire site
but there are also other challenges
the first is getting rid of radioactive
water more than one million tons of it
and there is no space to store more next
year
we have no possibility of building new
reservoirs to conserve contaminated
water
and we are awaiting the government's
decision after careful consideration of
the situation
but there is also the matter of
contaminated waste
14 million cubic meters of it
the contaminated waste is temporarily
stored for future disposal
in warehouses like here in futaba town
just three kilometers away
from the nuclear plant but until now no
one knows how or when
that will happen al jazeera futaba